hi everyone in this video I will discuss
the B cell development now peace and
development starts in the bone marrow
bone marrow is the primary lymphoid
organ where immune cells develop in the
early stage of b cell development it
takes place in the bone marrow
then later when B cells mature a little
bit it moves out to the secondary
lymphoid organs such as live node and
develops there so for the primary place
of P cell development is the bone marrow
inside the bone marrow there is an
austrian ich an Austrian ich is closer
to the bones when the osteocytes are
there and there is another niche known
as vascular niche around the blood
vessels in the east industrial niche
there are subtle cells known as stomata
cells now these two metal cells play a
crucial role in b cell development so
let us take a moment to learn more about
the stroma tell cells the straw metal
cells are actually supportive cells and
there are large adherent cells the Greek
word stroma means matters stromal cells
work like a substratum which holds the
Proby cells in a specific niche and also
influence their development by secreting
several cytokines which are very
important in B cell development we will
talk about these cytokines and the
signaling downstream to these cytokines
and how they are involved in B cell
development so stay tuned now inside the
industrial age there are hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cells and hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cells can give rise to
lymphoid progenitor cells which is not
shown here
ultimately this lymphoid progenitor
would give rise to a pre pro b-cell
which is a total immature stage of a
bezel at this stage B cell expresses
some adhesion molecules also this
pre-prohibition expresses a b-cell
lineage marker b2 to zero now also at
this stage B cell expresses another
transcription factor which is known as
EB F 1 and we would learn about EB F
once function and its role in b cell
development at this point of time the
bone marrows to matter cell expresses
adhesion molecules known as V cam one on
the other hand side the pre-pro b cell
expresses adhesion molecule known as v
LF for this v l4 and we can interaction
is very important for b cell development
now fear for we come one interaction
hold the pre-pro p cell near to these
bone marrow stromal cell Anish such that
stromal cell can influence its
development and also this VL a for and
we can one interaction give rise to
expression of another adhesion molecule
known as seek it and seek it has defined
role from the pre prabhu b cell after
the interaction of v-cam 1r v LF for it
start expressing seek it on the other
hand sides tomato cell expresses stem
cell factor or SEF this f CF and Cicotte
interaction is important clue for the
proliferative signal to be cell also
another chemical known as CX CL 12
mediated signaling is very important for
pre pro b-cell now at this point of time
two important phenomena happens one is c
Keaton s CF interaction
which give rise to a proliferative
signal and also at this point the ccl2
based signalling system give rise to
proliferative signal from this point
onwards the heavy chain DJ recombination
starts now as time progresses the only
Probie cell detaches from that specific
stomatal cell and goes and bind to
others to Myrtle cells which are il-7
secretive now il-7 has distinct role in
early Probie cell development
iu7 receptor is situated in the early
pro-v cell and il7 binds to aisle 7
receptor and this give rise to specific
signaling at this point of time vdj
recombination takes place so the b-cell
receptor which is basically membrane
bound and B IgM or anti jeje they are
they are actually produce the heavy
chain is produced from this point
onwards so let's just take a look what
il-7 mediated signal do so il7 bind to
its specific aisle 7 receptor on the
early Proby cell stage now it points to
the IL 7 receptor which is a tyrosine
kinase and which is the tyrosine kinase
receptor now along with it
Janus kinase is associated now jack gets
phosphorylated upon IL 7 pointing and it
allows phosphorylation of stacked 5 step
5 moves to the nucleus and start
transcription of em Mick and C meek also
it start transcribing EB F 1 and EB F 1
and stat5 both allow transcription of
pax5
EB F 1 is super important for dgh
recombination and also pax5 is very
important for fede
combination for the heavy chain
recombination paths Fife and EB F one
are super important these two
transcription factors ensures that the
heavy chain recombination takes place
properly now eb f 1e 2a and pax5
all these transcription factors actually
activates many genes which are important
for P cell lineage specification and P
cell proliferation
now once the early pros B cell stages
over
then comes the late pro B cell stage in
the late Pro B cell stage it starts
expressing a primitive version of a
primitive version of BC R which is known
as B cell receptor now at this point of
time you see the heavy chain of the B
cell receptor is formed but the light
chain at this point is not properly
formed so at this point the light chain
is known as the surrogate light chain
which comprised of V pre B or lambda v
but from this stage onwards the light
chain recombination would also start now
it would start expressing cd25
and high affinity il-2 receptor now it
now it would become a immature B cell in
the immature B cell in the immature B
cell you can see the light chain is now
formed and also another remarkable thing
is idol 7 receptor is star regulated in
the absence of il7 deceptor mediated
signaling the adhesion molecules would
be also down regulated so these immature
b-cells are detached from the bone
marrow stromal cell niche so now they
comes to the vascular dish and they
migrate via blood vessels and ultimately
reach lymph node which is a secondary
lymphoid organ now inside the lymph node
there are specific religions for
diesel and decel development so lymph
node is like an army base camp where
they get specific trainings now b-cell
at this point is imagine it's naive it
has not though it can recognize antigen
but it has not encountered real antigen
but in this germinal Center in the
specific b-cell zone it would interact
with dendritic cells and other antigen
projecting cells to recognize antigen
and it would either become a gente body
producing plasma cell or it would become
on memory P cell about B cell affinity
maturation and B cell activation I have
separate video so this is how P cell
development progressed from the bone
marrow and some part of the development
happens in the lymph node has been so if
you liked my video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to subscribe please
share and thank you